[Music]
the history of the brittle room burger
it started in New Jersey my partner Dean
piccolo at a steak house club Sebastian
he made me a burger for lunch and the
burger was the best burger I've ever had
my life like we have to have these on
the menu like how did you do this as
well we have all these trimmings these
aged meat trimmings from my steakhouse
and would I put together a burger and at
the time when we opened in 2010 the
higher end burgers in the city were
really really great but what we did was
we put a little less aged meat in it and
it's kind of like resonated with the
masses My partner Dean put this burger
together and it set was world famous now
[Music]
the burger is made with chuck
it also has short ribs in it it's got
the fat from the sirloin area and kidney
area and we have a portion of that which
is all aged so 25 percent aged meat in
our blends 65% fresh meat and 10% fat
extra flavorful fat the way we cook the
brindle room burger is we have our patty
we seasoned it generously with salt and
pepper
and then we get a scorching hot
cast-iron pan and get a super hard sear
on the burger what it does is it creates
a really nice crust on on top and get
the crust on the bottom and it cooks in
its own fat does it grill off if we put
one of these burgers on a on a backyard
fire grill you would have to call the
fire department
we turn the patty over we throw it into
the oven for a few minutes when we take
the burger out of the oven
place it back on the fire and we take
these wet caramelized onions and throw
them in the pan and then we invert
another pan on top so you have like a
little dome and the wet caramelized
onion as it steam from that helps makes
the cheese melt we suggest people either
with American
it melts perfectly it doesn't overwhelm
the burger with too many other flavors
we have a a cheap pedestrian burger bun
that's really meant to like be very
insignificant to the whole burger
experiencing the whole experience is
really about to be we close it up it
squishes down throw some hand-cut fries
and this is the brindle room burger
[Music]